this is just mind-blowing you turn on
some somebody's like channels FoxNews
and have some like so-called
like COD or Islamic expert on the show
have you seen them yeah of course
actually I did my PhD dissertation on
how Islam is portrayed on Fox News oh
yeah for five years I was watching five
fox news day and night and two things I
have now that I didn't have before I
started watching Fox News blood pressure
and heart attacks sheer lies total lies
you know and and they know that the
people who are watching they don't have
the background and they don't have the
proper knowledge of Islam so they just
they can spew hate and they can't just
say nonsense and many people are willing
to believe all you need to do is think
for yourself is this a bad religion if
it's a bad religion and the Quran is a
book of violence how come that Islam is
the fastest growing religion in the
world how come that so many people are
accepting this religion if Islam is so
violent and abusive to women how come
that 75% of our reverts to Islam are
women my name is Yvonne Ridley and my
name is nabila's are here the muslim
faith is under the spotlight again and
this time its detractors and critics are
wondering why
more women in the West are embracing
Islam than any other religion yes in
their eyes Islam is supposed to be a
religion which oppresses and subjugates
women or that's what the critics want
everyone else to think and the profile
of the new converts has them baffled
according to figures from a multi-faith
group called faith matters those most
likely to convert to Islam are career
women in their 20s and 30s the number
who have converted has now passed the
100,000 mark with 5,200 recorded last
year alone they are choosing to reject
the excesses of Western lifestyles such
as consumerism and immorality but before
we introduce to Muslim women with
amazing stories to tell so there has to
be something to it so all you need to do
it just read it with an open heart and
open mind and think for yourself you're
an intelligent you are intelligent
enough smart enough to read and think
for yourself don't let other people with
agendas do the thinking for you yeah
capitalize off your ignorant
with fear